confidence without evidence is delusion
the idea that you aren't confident if
you don't feel confident right now is
okay because the question is what are
you trying to be confident about like
confidence as a word is the percentage
likelihood that you have that what you
think will happen will happen like what
is our confidence score on this metric
and so the same thing applies to a
person what is our confidence that when
Johnny says he will do this it will
happen and so we have our own confidence
metric for ourself which is a percentage
likely that we will do what we say we're
going to do the way that you can
increase that confidence is to have more
evidence that you've done things when
you said you would them in the past I
think it's about looking retrospectively
and thinking you know what story can I
tell around this data that would give me
more evidence that I actually do have
some of these traits that I didn't think
about